(applaudissements)
- Avec le décès du metteur
ne André Brassard,
le Québec perd un pionnier,
et Michel Tremblay perd
son grand complice.
MICHEL TREMBLAY, dramaturge,
romancier et scénariste
- Cette nuit, évidemment,
j'ai peu dormi, la nuit
après son décès.
Et c'est effectivement le...
Je me suis joué dans la tête
le film de nos 40 ans.
- Je pense qu'il faut le faire
en joual.
Brassard avait
à peine 22 ans lorsqu'en 1968,
il signe la mise en scène
de la pièce "Les belles-soeurs"
de Michel Tremblay....
La complicité du tandem
Brassard-Tremblay a eu l'effet
d'une véritable petite
révolution dans le théâtre
québécois.
- Je pense qu'on avait
tous les deux... une parenté
dans le fait de retourner
es en quelque chose
de comique.
- Avec ses mises en scènes
ingénieuses et sa ion
des textes de Genet, Racine et
Shakespeare, André Brassard
était audacieux, passionné
et parfois sans compromis.mprom.
Dans les années 70,
Lorraine Pintal faisait partie
de son cercle rapproché.
LORRAINEir. gén. et
art., Théâtre du Nouveau Monde
- Finalement, j'ai découvert
un adolescent qui n'avait
jamais vieilli, qui... qui, lui,
ujours cette espèce
d'éblouissement devant
les acteurs, devant la pièce à
monter et quelqu'un aussi qui
avait une faille. Parce qu'o
le sait qu'il avait une faille,
André, c'était quelqu'un
de douloureux.
e verrez rien
de tout cela.
- Entre deux ovations,
en coulisse, la vie
d'André Brassard a été ponctuée
par la consommation de drogues
et d'épisodes de dépression.
En 1975, il a été condamné
pour grossière indédence
après qu'on eut retrouvé
chez lui des photos de jeunes
hommes âgés de 14 à 20 ans.
Il en avait à son biographe
Guillaume Corbeil.
GUILLAUME CORBEIL, écrivain
de la biographie "Brassard"
- J'aime me rappeler aussi...
Souvent, les gens qui font
des choses comme ça, ce sont
des gens qui souffrent. Puis,
comme je disais, André Brassard,
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas eu
d'amour, lui. C'est quelqu'un
parce que sa mère avait pas
le droit de le coller en public,
parce qu'il fallait pas qu'André
comprenne que c'était sa mère.
Et donc, c'est quelqu'un qui a
souffert toute sa vie d'un grand
manque d'amour.
- André Brassard a
tranquillement quitté la scène
après un accident vasculaire
cérébal survenu en 1999.
Lentement, mais sûremment,
le rideau est tombé.
- Il a tellement pas pris soin
de lui à partir du moment où
il a eu son premier AVC en 1999.
C'est ce qui nous a séparé,
d'ailleurs, c'est mon...
En fait, c'est mon exaspération
devant le fait que je trouvais
qu'il luttait pas assez qui a
fait qu'on a eu un problème
ensemble.
- Que ce soit au théâtre
ou au cinéma, André Brassard
nous a fait rire et pleurer.
Lui qui a toujours voulu
être aimé aura réussi à
nous transmettre son amour
du théâtre.
- Excusez-moi d'interrompre
cette chaleur...
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Mo